there are times when you're staring into
that dark
abyss and you go i'm gonna take the leap
sure out of film school i thought that
they were gonna hand us you know our
diploma and our three picture deal which
is the joke
where you just be of course i'll be
working
when the writing gets difficult which it
does it's the easiest time
to run away from it and i found
that even when you sit with it like i
think raymond chandler said he sat at
his desk every day at the same time
if he if anything happened or it didn't
you know it's that constant
repetition which writing is it's not oh
i'm
you know waiting for my muse
oh how amazing is to be a writer you're
like it is but
as a writer take the hollywood element
out it's it's you know
it's a grind you gotta write you know
you gotta come up with stuff all
35 scripts i think about i go how did i
channel that many stories through this
body
into these things i mean then i go there
won't be any others
in the well how could there be well
that's your job as a writer right to
come up with another story to come up
with another you know i mean that's the
beautiful part about going back to the
well
and having it be full of stuff and
that's where
your living comes into play your
experiences
and living an authentic life where
you're always like
observing and doing things because it's
your homework as a screenwriter to do
that
because you don't want to go back to
your well and have it be empty
a lot of people don't enjoy their day
job i mean it's okay
but they're working for the weekend or
they're working for something else and
i always saw my father not enjoy his job
and i said i wanna i wanna do something
that i want to get paid
to do and i may not make millions of
dollars
but to wake up and and sit down and
write and create for a living i still
kind of
get a you know kick out of him like oh
my gosh i get you know i'm living my
childhood dream
you know it's 11 year old kid making
films
to be able to you know see my name on
a large or small screen and be on the
set and see actors say the lines or work
you know do rewrites on the set and you
know interact with other creative people
then you're
you know it's just it was a dream
it has to start with you you have to
care about what you're writing
you know first and foremost and and
that'll show through if you're
if you're inauthentic where you're
trying to just
you know cheat and write something for
money or write something that's uh
you're trying to follow a trend and
copy something else you know it'll show
through and it won't be like
that's why i think uh my specs sold
because it was a heartfelt
and you know i think i poured it out on
the page
you know um because i i don't i don't
say this in the book but i
um during the time of starting the spec
i had lost a family member and so i
stopped writing
the script and i came back it took me
like six or eight months to finally
feel you know not guilty about working
on that
and i think a lot of that loss went into
the
the characters you know what i mean it
was like and so many times your own
life experiences which i think should
reflect in your work and make it that
authentic you know
if you don't believe in yourself why why
do you expect other people
to believe in you and it's your dream
um someone else will live their dream
and why shouldn't you live your dream
that was always my opinion
and it's scary because you don't know if
you're going to
or they will allow you to do it um
so you have to write something
that you care about but also that
somebody else sees
you know that care in there and and
wants to make it then then the business
part becomes
they want to invest millions of dollars
in your idea as opposed to somebody
else's idea
faith in yourself first and foremost
don't search outward for it
you know like looking looking for
validation from outside to get that you
know like oh i'll write something and
if somebody an agent likes it then that
validates me
you know no no and have faith in your
abilities
first and foremost and then go out there
and see what happens
i say there's no fame and fortune in the
screenwriting game
i mean you know it's it's uh when you
have most uh
half of the writers and the writers
guild don't don't work every year
and those are professional wga writers i
think the odds last year were like 5
200 or something out of approximately 10
000. so the other half are looking for
jobs and not working you know or the 50
000 scripts that are apparently
registered with the guild every year um
those are just the ones registered or
the 70 to 100 specs a year that sell
you know i always tell writers i don't
bring up those odds to scare you
but for you to realize what you're up
against you know you wouldn't go climb
mount everest without the training and
the help and the tools
you just go okay i'm gonna go do it. now
there's a certain uh
courage in doing that but there's also a
certain stupidity at some time
you know and i always say to uh aspiring
screenwriters
treat it like your job because it will
be you don't have the luxury of when you
write your specs to go ah
i'm gonna go off today work on it for
five minutes ten minutes whatever it is
but that constant
is what's gonna happen when you get the
assignment jobs
and you know you don't wanna be shocked
when suddenly you
get this opportunity you're hired to
write a movie and you can't
physically sit there for eight hours a
day or you can't write it in
30 days or you can't write it in eight
weeks or however much time you've agreed
to write the screenplay you will be
shocked because you're not training
as you know you know it's it's a step
deal so whenever anything sells
you know it's in steps and you may not
get the final steps
so when a screenplay sells you get a
little bit of money and then a little
bit of money for the next draft the next
and that has to be made for you to get
the bonus
so everyone thinks that just because a
script sells suddenly you're you know
everybody's calling on the phone and
things like that so
i would say that was not difficult to
revisit
but you know i think about the time i
put myself back into the time that's
what i was trying to do when i was
writing
because i'm a very visual person and i
can really have this sense of memory
and the back of the time it wasn't funny
you know it was very
uh it was like oh my gosh so now i've
i've done this
and still i have to do this and you're
like yeah
many times you have to live in these two
these two parallel worlds and that can
mess with your head a lot
so you have to be really grounded and
say this is the reality of it
and it doesn't um it doesn't uh
it's not the image of who i am i am a
writer
if i'm catering or always doing anything
else at the time you know
okay so how i was fired from my first
professional job at christmas right at
christmas time
you know um but it happens and then you
you're not guaranteed
anything you know the hardest thing that
i had to learn when i first started
getting paid to write was that i thought
everything i wrote would get made
of course it would be well i have
probably five projects sitting on a
shelf that are production ready i was
paid for all the drafts and
nothing a myriad of reasons because
the marketplace changes economics uh
their buyers decided to go with a
different genre the actor bowed out and
they want you know
financing fell through all things that
were not my
problem you know i'm just the writer
right but
that was the hardest thing uh but i i
mean it's not hard anymore i realized
the realities of the business that not
you know and
but that was the hardest thing i thought
everything i wrote would be made
i thought that when i wrote my specs of
course obviously too
every spec you write is going to sell
right it's hard rejection
criticism if you put yourself out there
you're going to be criticized
and many people don't finish things i
find because if they never finish it
they'll never know that it sucks
and they'll never be criticized because
they're still working on it
you know it's a work in progress for a
number of years like did you finish that
i'm still working on it that's a safe
place to be then putting it out there
and getting smacked around and that's
only that's that's how you learn that's
the only way you're going to learn
one time i was in a meeting with a
producer and i had never worked with him
before and i was working
on assignment and he said something off
the cuff
which was kind of insulting like um
could you explain it to him it's like
screenwriting 101
and i look i was like and almost i it
went over my head and i thought
oh my gosh he just insulted me
and i let it go but i was like who are
you talking i
you know i get it but you don't get i
don't know how you work
you're all over the place i'm trying to
grasp a thing which changes to another
thing and i'm like ah
but you can't be right you can't say
that
you know you can it's a fine line you
got to know how to how to uh
you know apply yourself when you need to
and and not just like like with uh
fighting your battles with notes you
know i had a friend in film school he
would he would self-sabotage because he
never
wanted to uh he was a rule breaker
i'mma break all the rules so he'd write
these scripts that were like
double the size of a script and the
wrong cover
you know all these things right up front
and they would just put him in the trash
and he is extremely knowledgeable about
film
i mean like crazy but it didn't
translate into
the realities of the business and so
he's like oh i said well you can break
the rules once you know them
and you're in but you're trying to be
this maverick
and nobody cares you know and he really
hard head
you know just wouldn't listen and uh
that i think was self-sabotaging you
know it you know i mean it's still i
don't know to this day if he listens but
i'm not sure it was the time when uh i
sold my
spec and i was in the trade papers in
variety
and every writer wants to be in variety
right then you say oh i made it right
well the day that i was in variety the
headline was this new company
had formed and they they optioned my
script and they were going to buy it and
make it into their first movie
and that day in variety i had to do a
catering job
at one of the biggest producers uh in
hollywood's house and so
it was this catering company and my
friend and i drove up to beverly hills
and here we're at this giant mansion of
this producer
and uh it was a big breakfast meeting
with
big you know power players uh former
prime minister of a middle eastern
country
you know security everywhere and i was
thinking wow
you know i'm in variety today why should
i be catering you know
and also i was thinking in a way which
is in the book um what if this producer
had
had you know rejected my screenplay and
here i am in his house serving him
coffee
you know so just be careful about who
you um you know disrespect
uh you know on the way up or down
because you know
you just might end up in your in their
house pouring coffee for them you know
the important thing too
is to have people around you that
support your endeavor
because i've lost friendships and i've
lost relationships
with people who said well and they drew
a line in the sand
and they said and i was like that's not
a good thing to do
and what about the last x number of
years i've been doing this you're just
going to throw let me throw that away
you know the the lack of understanding
about how much
filmmaking and writing was such a part
of my being almost that
other creative endeavors like drawing
and things like that but but
this is like who i am and to have
someone with you not
understand that it's really you know and
that's the hardest part that
so many elements just like in making a
film
so many elements have to go together and
all click
same way with forging a career when i
was working at the law firm for two
years
at lunch i would write i would write by
hand
but i wanted to like not just sit there
and be like uh
you know so every day at lunch that was
an hour that's five hours a week
including the time at night then at six
o'clock make dinner and then
write until midnight and then go to bed
seven a.m go to that job
it was having two jobs at once and then
on the weekends
people would say oh come on do this and
that i said well i have to write right
what are you talking about i said well
and it was it was terribly exhausting
and i can see how it can chip away
you know at you especially if you have a
family
and a lot of different concerns pulling
at you um that's why you have to really
close the door and say this is my time
um and it had it cannot be interrupted
and
that's it is hard to do but you really
have to stay disciplined and also i
think you have to have the fire
and burning passion to really want it
more than anything else
day one of pages is like starting a new
job
except it's at my office you know it's
the same familiar surroundings but it's
starting a new job
and luckily there wasn't a great amount
of time between
me finishing the treatment and
and the company saying go
because i like it when it's fresh still
that i can jump right on
rather than this you know there's a
momentum that's really important about
things like that
for me i have to see the film in my head
before i can write it
and i know that i i'm i have a lot of
problems ahead of me if i can't see it
i mean i don't i don't lock in like i've
almost seen the movie
like like when you watch a movie you
remember it i have to see it that way
and i know things are working when i
start to live
and you know the outline's good for
living with your characters
you know you get to live with them you
get to you get to
see how the movie is working or it
doesn't work before
you sit down and write that screenplay
which is building the house you know
that's almost the pre-blueprint
in my opinion that's been my experience
but i know a lot of writers
just want to write down a couple of
lines and and wing it
and there's so many so many things that
can go wrong and why
why not turn in your the most amazing
first draft you can
i don't see the the problem with that
you have to have uh
ideas that you have to have log lines
that you're working on
then you also have to have some
treatments or one sheets which are
a lot easier to do than write a complete
screenplay and then you also have to
have your screenplay that you're working
on
but constantly when you go into a
meeting with your spec
that gets you the meeting they're not
buying that spec they just want to meet
you say oh i can see your ability and
then they say
what else you have and you don't want
that to be well i'm working on something
and it's going to take me six months
i'm not going to see you for six months
or you're not going to be on my radar
for six months
you want to say i have this other thing
you don't want to
bring you know a suitcase full of
scripts but you want to have this other
thing oh
well after the meeting send it over bam
you know what i mean you have to have
multiple projects in the marketplace i
think at all times because
not all of them and maybe not one of
them but
that's what you're up against that's why
i say when writers are doing their specs
set your own
self imposed deadline don't let it be
open-ended where
you know oh yeah i was working on this
last year and christmas
came but you know because you're going
to need that training
you know and even while you're working
in it with experience it's still
difficult
you got to stand because you're your own
boss no one's no one's calling me saying
are you working today
and the day goes on and then you know i
mean you got to really stay on it
and realize um there's a lot of
self-work i mean it's like
you're your own boss and it's good in
one way people say oh i would love to do
that
but with that comes a lot of
responsibility i didn't sit down to
write a book initially i was blogging
and i wanted to get my past 20 years of
professional experience somehow out
of my you know mind and heart
and try to be able to share it with
people and so after
five or six years of blogging i realized
that i had enough
information to you know create something
and so i started the process of
stripping down the articles
and refabricating them into you know
into chapters
and and then i thought well i'm going to
chart my journey from
how i started uh in the business
as a filmmaker at 11 years old you know
what what was that spark that creative
spark
and chart it all the way until today
and not so much as a memoir but also
using
examples and funny anecdotal stories but
you know disciplines that i've used that
have helped me
you know stay in the game that hopefully
other other writers will be able to see
and go oh yeah
i'm not doing that or i need to do that
as i say it's hard i'm living proof that
it does happen
and there's no guarantees but i always
say the only guarantee
in screenwriting is that you stop
writing
you're definitely guaranteed never to
have any chance at success
so as long as you're in the game you
have a shot
and then you realize the day's gone
you're like i should be on page 15
and i'm on three